ralph waldo emerson is the father of
american literature
in a series of strikingly original
essays written in the mid-19th century
he fundamentally changed the way that
america saw its cultural and artistic
possibilities
and he enabled a separation from
transatlantic
literary traditions we have listened too
long he wrote to the courtly muses of
europe emerson's ejection of cultural
traditions
brought about what one contemporary
called america's
intellectual declaration of independence
and he established generational conflict
and transformation
as commanding ideas in american
literature
emerson himself hardly seemed destined
to fit a revolutionary mold
he was born in 1803 the son of a boston
preacher
and was descended from a line of new
england ministers that went back to the
bedrock of 17th century puritanism when
his father died in 1811
his mother took in borders to pay the
rent still she sent her son to harvard
in 1817
and then harvard divinity school to
train for the priesthood in 1825.
as a young man emerson was strongly
influenced by a remarkable
aunt of his mary moody emerson who
though self-taught
had read everything from shakespeare to
the romantics and had formed a unique
religious perspective
based on piety nature and literature
that would resonate powerfully in the
life and work of her nephew
so when emerson was ordained in 1829
marrying the love of his life ellen
tucker in the same year
he was already unsatisfied with the
formal nature
of new england religious orthodoxy when
ellen died of tuberculosis just two
years later
he resigned from the church and soon
after embarked on a trip to europe
leaving on christmas day 1832 two
crucial things happened to emerson on
that tour of europe
in paris he went to the famous giardande
plant
a botanical and zoological garden there
he had an epiphany
writing in his journal that i feel the
centipede
in me the caiman carp eagle and fox
i am moved by strange sympathies i say
continually
i will be a naturalist emerson's insight
was that nature is in us a part of us
and not just its higher forms but in all
its grotesquery
and wildness the second thing that
happened on that tour
was that emerson met the english
romantic poets samuel taylor coleridge
and william wordsworth
and found them rather ordinary dry and
conservative men
the insight that emerson drew from this
was that if great men could be so
ordinary
why should not ordinary men be great as
he would write a few years later
meek young men grow up in libraries
believing it their duty
to accept the views which cicero lock
bacon have given
forgetful that cicero lock and bacon
were only young men in libraries when
they wrote these books
emerson had found two ideas that would
guide his life's work
that man and nature are one and that
everyone can recognize that they are a
uniquely
significant human being on his return to
america in 1833
emerson became a professional lecturer
giving talks on natural history and
literature
in halls around new england he remarried
and had several children
presenting a solid bourgeois appearance
to the world
but his inner life was full of
turbulence and originality
in his 1836 essay nature emerson
outlined the germ of a new philosophy
a key element of this was the importance
of american
originality in its opening lines emerson
wrote
our age is retrospective it builds the
sepulchers of the fathers
it writes biographies histories and
criticism the foregoing generations
beheld god
and nature face to face we through their
eyes why should not we also enjoy an
original relation to the universe
america needed to stop looking back to
its european heritage
and start looking about itself no past
moment was more important
than the present moment no tradition was
more important
than novelty no generation was better
than the current generation
everything that matters is here now
insisted emerson
and that here was america this was an
extension of emerson's
ideas about the significance of the
individual that came under the heading
of what he called self-reliance
everywhere emerson looked he saw people
leading lives that were based on
tradition
that were limited by religious forms and
social habits
no one could be themselves emerson
thought because they were all too busy
being what they were supposed to be
emerson wanted to get rid of each of
these burdens the past
religion and social forms so that each
person could find out who they
truly were as he put it history is an
impertinence and an
injury our religion we have not chosen
but society has chosen for us and
society everywhere is in conspiracy
against the manhood of every one of its
members
we must he argued live from within
trusting nothing but our own intuitions
for as he concluded nothing is at last
sacred but the integrity of your own
mind this leaves open a vital question
what is your nature
once you have rid yourself of history
tradition and religion
what can be said is that it isn't
necessarily self-indulgence hedonism or
narcissism
rather it's the surrender to that force
which emerson recognized
back in the jardin de plant an obedience
to nature itself by nature
emerson seemed to mean the natural world
plants animals rocks and sky
but what he really meant was god
emerson was a pantheist that is someone
who believed that god exists in every
part of creation
from the smallest grain of sand to the
stars but also crucially that the divine
spark is in
each of us in following ourselves we are
therefore not merely being fickle or
selfish
we are rather releasing a divine will
that history
society and organized religion normally
hide from us
the individual as emerson writes is a
god
in ruins but we have it within us by
casting off all custom
to rebuild ourselves emerson makes this
pantheist connection
explicit in what are perhaps his most
famous lines
crossing a bear common in snow puddles
at twilight under a clouded sky
without having in my thoughts any
occurrence of special good fortune
i have enjoyed a perfect exhilaration
i am glad to the brink of fear standing
on the bare ground
my head bathed by the blithe air and
uplifted into infinite space
all mean egotism vanishes i become
a transparent eyeball i am nothing
i see all the currents of the universal
being
circulate through me i am part or
particle of god
in the romantic tradition on which
emerson draws
it is the sublime great mountains
rushing torrents dark forests
which releases the inner vision as we
find ourselves in all
of them for emerson it's a perfectly
dull walk across an
ordinary common on a dark winter's
evening that brings him
to the brink of fear emerson's god
is in the snow puddles too stood there
on the common
he disappears becoming nothing as the
currents of god flow
through him what is left is just a
transparent
eyeball such transcendent moments are
rare
but they reveal an essential connection
between nature god
and man they are one they also give for
emerson
a proper sense of each individual's
importance as a part of god
transcendentalism became the name of the
movement
that grew up around emerson at this time
another aspect of the epiphany that was
to have a profound effect on american
literature
was the emphasis on the value of the
ordinary
what emerson put forward in essays like
the american scholar
and the poet was that the american every
day
was a proper subject for literature this
was because for emerson
the transcendentalist god is everywhere
and it's the poet's job to reveal this
there is no object he wrote so foul that
intense light will not make it beautiful
even the corpse has its own beauty this
coming from a man
who had opened his first wife's tomb a
year after her death
to take a look the great american
writers
who followed emerson were liberated by
his work
to look around and write about what they
saw and how they lived
transforming the everyday into a vital
symbol of something higher and more
elusive
henry david thoreau's two years at
walden pond
became a book that showed the cosmos
reflected in the depths of the waters
of a mere pond the poet walt whitman
said
i was simmering simmering simmering
emerson
brought me to a boil emily dickinson
heard a fly and could right of the other
side of death
the novelist hermann melville took a
whaling voyage
and made it an allegory of american
imperialism and the defiance of nature
in the 20th century the american critic
harold bloom
looked back at emerson's originality and
saw in it the origin of
the strong tradition of american poets
from robert frost and wallis stevens to
john ashbury
emerson's legacy to american literature
and culture
and indeed to the world was one of
ceaseless invention
and forward momentum as he put it i
unsettle
all things no facts are to me sacred
none are profane i simply experiment
an endless seeker with no past at my
back
people have always had trouble
pronouncing his name if you don't speak
german it's not at all obvious how
you're supposed to say it
a safe bet is to start with a hard was a
great czech writer
who has come to own a part of the human
emotional spectrum
which we can now call the kafka esque
and which thanks to him
were